we actually have this story this is a
big story right now um the daily mail
reports national guard is preparing for
a major cyber attack that would bring
down utilities across the u.s
troops tackle massive simulated breach
during two-week training exercise
after hack of colonial pipeline brought
nation's fuel supply to its knees
all right i i think they're taking it
seriously
i'm worried that they're taking it
seriously way too late
but yeah um was this on the list was
this on the list of the
the critical infrastructure that you're
not that our playbook of here's the
things that you should attack
thank you very much that was one of
these stupid i can't believe it what was
it exactly
biden said something to putin right
that's what this is so he gave he gave a
list
of like here are our most critical
infrastructure things here's
off-limits here's what you can't attack
so implicitly he's saying
like it's okay if you attack other
things just don't detect this and then
also
he's basically saying here are our most
important things so if you are a bad
nefarious guy
here are the things that you want to i
mean just the the strategy behind that
like
who's advising on that because we know
it's probably not coming
from joe biden right so who's the genius
who came up
with the list of the infrastructure and
what's that on the list
i can only hope that whoever advised him
says here's the 16 things we really
don't care about
tell him we care about it so that he
goes after that i see four
chess right right like small businesses
you could totally take out main street
we don't care about that yeah
no but i i i think the simple solution
one that makes the least amount of
assumptions joe biden was like
oh russia better not attack the things
we actually need hey hey putin i'm
warning you don't
don't attack these don't attack these
you know what i'm saying and here's the
list
it's the playground it's like the
playground bully it's like okay okay
you can you can beat me up but don't
break my glasses because my mom's gonna
be mad and she's gonna ground me
she'll ground you when you get beat up i
i
i couldn't believe that story right so
it's like they're doing war games now
it's like it's like negative 1d chess
yeah
really is it's like it's like you're
playing checkers with somebody
but joe biden's going like come on come
on man i don't know how to move i don't
even know the rules and you're like joe
joe it's like you just move diagonally
it's monopoly you just buy boardwalk put
some houses on it
you know i guess what's what's crazy
about this
is uh daily mail has been saying
russia did all of these hacks like
that's been the median narrative the
whole time
so when colonial pipeline got hit by
these hackers daily mail just
kept saying russian hack on on us
russian hack on yes and i'm like no
that's confirmed even biden said we
don't know for sure
but there were elements of the media
saying it was a russian attack or
russian attributed a russian associated
and and you know what it feels like it's
like we're back on schedule because uh
before donald trump got in office this
was everything that was happening you
know russia annexed crimea
then the the us and and nato and western
allies were getting involved in ukraine
there was
separatist conflict and then trump gets
in and all of a sudden this fades away
well i'll tell you something else that
was interesting all of the things that
were involved
were things that were sort of
progressive agenda items that they
wanted to crack down on so you had a
pipeline which obviously we know that
the
the natural gas issue is out there we
had meat
which was another issue and then it was
you were using using crypto to pay for
this
and we know that the us government's
really uncomfortable so the fact that
all sort of
elements of the story all revolved
around things that the government
you know doesn't really have on their
agenda is sort of an interesting thing
for me as well
did you hear that there was gas there
are gas stations out of gas in colorado
this past
week or so so there's a there's an
interesting story behind um part of the
the disruption
and that's with the government's you
know deciding
winners and losers and sort of
interfering in the economy
there are not enough drivers able to
drive the tanker trucks
and so it's now taking an extra couple
of days to get
the gas to the gas stations and the
people who used to be the tanker truck
drivers
you know they went to work for amazon or
they found other jobs or they're staying
home or whatnot
you can't just pull a random person off
the street and say go
drive a tanker truck right that's a
specialized thing so that's part of this
supply chain disruption that supposedly
nobody
expected we've had a lot of people super
chat us saying that's
not the case that you know they're
people like i'm a trucker there's no
shortage
this is not true now i can't you know
verify a super chat
but i'm i'm i'm i've gotten emails from
people saying they're truckers and it's
not the case
the challenge is if the media says it
and we all
believe it but then people were like hey
i'm a trucker that's not true it's like
who do you trust
do you trust the media i'm like that's
that's a tough call no right
i can't trust any of it i mean and it's
anecdotal at best if someone's super
chats and they're like hey
it worked i saw it so it's real
everywhere like i saw it here so
everywhere right exactly
it may be in their particular area or
their particular company as well
you mentioned in the previous segment
how there's like maybe a tie-in with
china's move against crypto and stuff
and we we have talked about all of the
moves made during the pandemic
and its potential relationship to a
coming war so a few things i've said is
not to imply a conspiracy i'm not saying
that i'm saying how fortuitous for the
united states
based on what happened so you have
decentralization from major cities
if a city gets nuked well half a million
people leave new york and many of these
people are leaders in industry or
high-ranking individuals in certain
companies
and they're working from home in
different areas so now it's harder
to to take out our economy because you
can't just go after one city you still
can't you kind of can
and then you you look at what's going on
with like gas stations having limited
fuel
a lot of it feels like there's something
happening behind the scenes we don't
know about
we don't have a very strong journalistic
apparatus in this country to inform us
about what's going on
and maybe the picture is just too big at
this point for any one organization
or individual to see but i look at all
this and i'm wondering if like look our
critical infrastructure gets attacked
that's oil pipelines
and it's meat production which was like
i think a fifth of all meat production
then i saw the story about a gas
shortage in colorado and i'm like now
explain to me how that happens like oh
it's a trucker shortage
then i hear from people who are like bro
i'm a trucker there's no shortage
then where's the gas and who do i trust
well the media has not been
you know faithful i should say honest to
the american people
i honestly don't know now you look at
what's happening with you know crimea
and in the uk
you look at china and taiwan sending 28
planes in the taiwanese defense zone and
i'm like
is it possible that the things we're
seeing with like gas snapping at gas
stations
critic critical infrastructure being
attacked and uh you know just these
these international
conflicts that we are dangerously close
to a real conflict and
both the you know the us as well as
russia china are shoring up the defenses
stockpiling preparing or something like
that
i mean i never take anything off the
table i leave all options open i think
that there's um you know some other
central planning issues that are going
on here which we'll definitely get into
but
i i wouldn't take that off the table i
mean based on history and based on what
we know about truthfulness
coming out of government central
planning and like you said the
sort of media or the the corporate press
complicity in terms of all of this
i i want to take it off the table i
think when you talk about central
planning it makes me think of the swiss
bank
bank of international settlements we
mentioned earlier a little bit that it
is like a global
central financial authority that is
trying like
using you know these lockheed martin and
these big
big arms dealers to like play chess with
all these countries and they're using
our military as
pawns against each other yeah it's
interesting i mean i do i tend to be a
little bit more domestic
focused and we certainly have at least
today
you know most of the wealth in the world
and i kind of feel like the central
planners in our country
like most central planners think that
they know better than they actually do
i don't know that i buy the global
conspiracy because i feel like
if you have that central power like why
are you sharing it with these other guys
over there i mean we know that
cartelization never works somebody
always breaks off
and so i feel like like we're we're
probably the leaders
of that so if there's something that's
going on it's probably starting with us
because i mean we've got the financial
center
we've got the the wealth we've got the
innovation
so the idea that there's some other
puppet master in switzerland
not to say that they're not doing things
in europe with the ecb
and whatnot but that they're actually
controlling the us narrative
unless they're just smarter than our
central planners which is i mean
anybody could pick five people out of
the phone book and there's central
planners
um you know i don't know it's an
interesting interesting discussion
i'm not a big fan of you know the big
bang conspiracies or anything like that
i certainly think we have a problem with
the fed
yeah we have a big bank conspiracy with
the federal reserve here in the united
states you know you know what's funny is
like
it is a conspiracy isn't it you know the
definition of conspiracy a group of
people doing some
committing some amoral unethical or
criminal act in secret
i mean that was literally the founding
of the fact i actually talked about it
in the book
um the founding of the fed that the idea
that it was decentralized this cloak of
decentralization
uh which i sourced back if you want to
read like deep dive on this it's a book
called the uh the case against the fed
by dr murray
rothbard who's a now deceased economist
who's great uh
but like the way that they founded the
fed was completely
to have this uh kind of bait-and-switch
feel on the american public so oh no
we're decentralized we're not part of
the government
but when you think about the fed so i
mean this is really messed up so it's
owned by
its its member banks but if it makes a
profit
that goes back to the u.s treasury not
to its
owners it gets its mandate from congress
but
congress doesn't have any ability to
know or audit what's actually going on
so is it part of the government is it
decentralized
the way that it's described is it sort
of a a big
bank government cartel yeah and they
call it federal
gives me control of a nation's currency
and i care not who makes its laws ross
child
yeah is that what you have nathan shell
roth
i saw that quote earlier today yeah uh
bavarian was amshell the bavarian banker
i mean he's like the guy that founded
the central bank basically and then he
had three kids i think it was amshah he
had three kids one went to england one
went to france and one went somewhere
else
and it was the one in england that
really created this global banking
influence yeah which which founding
father was who said that centralized
banking is more powerful than any
standing army jefferson was it jefferson
yeah
man those guys were smart weren't they
they understood yeah i mean they warned
against this
and they had tried to do these central
banking structures before
landing on the fed and national banking
structures and they had all failed
and so this was kind of like okay let's
let's rejigger it
and the funny part was that the national
bank that they had put in place that was
put in place by these bankers like the
the morgans and you know these kind of
financiers
they felt like they didn't have enough
control even though they were the ones
who
had structured it and so that's why they
came up with this concept of what the
fed is today
and by the way so it started out with
sort of these nefarious intentions and
has gone completely off the rails since
then
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you